Let us now discuss an
interesting fact about
independence that should enhance
our understanding.
Suppose that events A and
B are independent.
Intuitively, if I tell you that
A occurred, this does not
change your beliefs as to the
likelihood that B will occur.
But in that case, this should
not change your beliefs as to
the likelihood that
B will not occur.
So A should be independent
of B complement.
In other words, the occurrence
of A tells you nothing about
B, and therefore tells
you nothing about
B complement either.
This was an intuitive argument
that if A and B are
independent, then A and
B complement are also
independent.
But let us now verify
this intuition
through a formal proof.
The formal proof goes
as follows.
We have the two events, A and
B. And event A can be broken
down into two pieces.
One piece is the intersection
of A with B. So that's the
first piece.
And the second piece is the part
of A which is outside B.
And that piece is A intersection
with the
complement of B. So these are
the two pieces that together
comprise event A.
Now, these two pieces are
disjoint from each other.
And therefore, by the additivity
axiom, the
probability of A is equal
to the probability of A
intersection B plus the
probability of A intersection
with B complement.
Using independence, the first
term becomes probability of A
times probability of B. And we
leave the second term as is.
Now let us move this term
to the other side.
And we obtain that the
probability of A intersection
with B complement is the
probability of A minus the
probability of A times the
probability of B. We factor
out the term probability of A,
and we are left with 1 minus
probability of B. And then we
recognize that 1 minus the
probability of B is the same
as the probability of B
complement.
So we proved that the
probability of A and B
complement occurring together
is the product of their
individual probabilities.
And that's exactly the
definition of A being
independent from B complement.
And this concludes
the formal proof.